we've not really discussed many of the
locations found within the Cthulhu
Mythos and there are some quite
interesting and intriguing ideas the
topic of this video is the Dreamlands an
alternative universe that can only be
accessed through one the streams the
Dreamlands mirror our very own universe
in almost every aspect especially in
terms of geographical locations on earth
and how the universe and planets around
us are arranged the main difference
between the two universes is in the way
that time works what feels like years in
the Dreamlands can be little more than a
single night when awake the Dreamlands
also contains civilizations and
creatures such as the moon beasts these
zoogs and the googs
which not only sound like they were made
up by a child but also don't appear in
the wake in realm
Lovecraft makes reference to the
Dreamlands in a very dozen of his
stories which have come to be known as
the dream cycle with the first been a
story he wrote in 1918 titled Polaris
this story features an unnamed narrator
who is continuously dreaming of a city
under siege
eventually the narrator finds himself
transported to the city known as olive
though in physical form as one of its
inhabitants the city is breached by
invaders and the narrator is sent to the
watchtower to signal that the city is
under attack when he gets to the top he
hears a strange rhyme that he can't
quite understand and in trying to
decipher it he falls asleep and wakes up
back in his house the narrator is
convinced that this reality is in fact a
dream that he can't wake from meaning
that he has failed the city this idea of
a dream inside of a dream and not
knowing which reality is real is even
more trippy and Lovecraft's work as the
dream lands our physical plane that one
can travel too similar to astral
projection entering the dream land
however isn't as easy as just falling
asleep once in a deep slumber the
dreamer must find a peculiar looking
staircase called the seventy steps of
light slumber this set of stairs then
takes you to the cavern of flame where
you will be judged by the gatekeepers
gnashed and commands are these two
addressed as Egyptian priests and
ultimately they have the last safe you
may enter some consider these two to be
gods but to most they are merely just
priests who serve the great old ones if
they do decide that a dreamer is worthy
then they can be asked anything about
the dream lands as they possess a vast
amount of knowledge the dreamer then
encounters the 700 steps of deep slumber
which lead to the enchanted wood if all
of these stages have been completed then
the dreamers leave their physical body
safely
there are those however that belief some
of this process can be avoided though it
isn't recommended as this can lead to
what is called a dream death meaning
one's dream self dies and they can never
return to the dream lands in some cases
this can also cause a great shock to
one's corporeal body the same can be
said for waking someone up from their
dream as well as potentially harming
their physical body their dream self
disappears and they have no memory of
what they've seen or experienced the
dream lands can also be entered
physically but it makes death a
permanent reality there are some
benefits to enter in the dreamland in
this way and they include being able to
stay as long as you like or as normally
you would have to leave when you wake up
you can also have an extended lifespan
equal to that of the dream lands natives
now whether that's worth the risk of a
permanent death is solely down to the
individual the dream lands that are
referred to by Lovecraft and other
authors are accessible to humans mainly
by their dreams but other civilizations
and planets have their own dream lands
traveling between these lands is
possible it's just very difficult all of
the dream ins are ruled by a set of
deities known as the great ones or the
other ones not to be confused with the
great old ones or the outer gods who
have next and no interest in the dream
lands the great ones can be wounded
deceived and seduced by mortals so they
aren't really what you'd expect from
gods even at times been referred to as
the weak gods of Earth they are however
protected by nian Arthur Thep who is
also their messenger a job that he
surely despises because protect and the
great ones must seem like babysitting
children
now we can divide the Dreamlands into
four continental regions and six places
of note the four continents are named
after each cardinal direction the north
is a cold mountainous terrain inhabited
by man-eating spiders and say tear like
creatures called the men of Leng the
great ones are also said to live in the
most northern peaks in their Castle
Kadath the lands in the east are the
least inhabited of all four they are
however home to the greatest dream of
all King kuranes who created the entire
city of celephaïs zhh in a dream beyond
this city are the forbidden lands which
as the name suggests are a dangerous
place that no dreamer should ever pass
through the West is the most well known
region because it is where new arrivals
emerge from these steps of deep slumber
on the western coast you have the
largest city of the Dreamlands the port
of diethylene further along you have the
jungle city known as clan F and the
desert trading capital of Yannick
along the border joining the South you
have the ruins of Sarnath and the
enchanted wood the home of the Zhuge for
those of you that love cats there is
also the city of alpha where no cat is
allowed to be slain the south contains
the island of ori app but much of the
south is referred to as the fantastic
realms because it contains horrors and
wonders that one can never truly
comprehend beneath the entirety of the
Dreamlands you have what is considered
the underworld
a series of subterranean crypts and
tunnels inhabited by the gags and the
ghouls the final place of note is the
moon which is home to the moon beasts
who serve nyan Arthur tip the Dreamlands
are definitely an interesting concept
especially if you enjoy ideas such as
parallel universes and astral projection
let me know how you feel about the dream
lands and if you've read any stories
that mention them in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
in fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]